back in down in street but this not a
time for celebration I'm sorry I've been
away from my desk for much longer than I
would have liked
after three weeks battling his personal
coronavirus crisis back to tackling the
country's every day I know that this
virus brings new sadness and mourning to
households across the land and it is
still true that this is the biggest
single challenge this country has faced
since the war and yet it is also true
that we are making progress and real
signs now that we are passing through
the peak he knows how hard it's been
getting to this point if this virus were
a physical assailant an unexpected and
invisible mugger which I can tell you
from personal experience it is then this
is the moment when we have begun
together to wrestle it to the floor this
is the moment of opportunity it is also
the moment of maximum risk because I
know there will be many people looking
now at our apparent success and
beginning to wonder whether now is the
time to go easy on those social
distancing measures under pressure from
some to relax lockdown for the economy's
sake but resist him for now and so yes I
entirely share your urgency it's the
government's urgency and yet we must
also recognize the risk of a second
spike because that would mean not only a
new wave of death and disease but also
an economic disaster
I refuse to throw away all the effort
and the sacrifice of the British people
and I ask you to contain your impatience
because I believe we are coming now to
the end of the first phase of this
conflict
and the second phase will require grit
too if we can share the same spirit of
unity and determination as we've all
shown in the past six weeks then I have
absolutely no doubt that we will beat it
together we will come through this all
the faster and the United Kingdom will
emerge stronger than ever before the
Prime Minister's return to work is
undoubtedly a moment of success in this
grim coronavirus crisis he has survived
but sadly tens of thousands have not we
are passing through the peak and
everyone now is counting the cost some
much more than others everyone wants to
move on but the Prime Minister marked
his return to work by managing those
lock down expectations the government
knows it needs to keep the public with
them this a new initiative at the daily
news conference will take off first
questions from a member of the public
this is going to become a regular
feature of these briefings the questions
are selected by an independent polling
organization and now we're going to go
to the first question which is from Lin
in Skipton and I'm going to read out the
question and I'm reading it for the
first time and then we will endeavor to
answer it I'm missing my grandchildren
so much please can you let me know if
after the five criteria are met is being
able to hug our closest family one of
the first steps out of lockdown we all
know how hard this is my own mother
lives hundreds of miles away and I know
she's wondering when she will be seeing
me and her grandchildren again this is
really tough but as the secretary state
has said it is bearing fruit in that we
are seeing reduction in the number of
hospital admissions we're seeing a
reduction in the number of deaths and
other very difficult questions - such as
why the UK death rate has far exceeded
initial expectations the number will
definitely see 20,000 we need to view
this epidemic over the long run and this
has got a very long way to run
and I'm really cautious about putting
out and I've said this again repeatedly
these kind of absolute numbers because
this could go in a lot of different ways
over the next many months until such
time as we have a clear exit into our
sixth week of lockdown normal life feels
a world away and the PM guarded today
about what comes next but he knows he'll
have to give the public more in the
coming days and he knows - there are no
easy answers Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster